so we've got a symbol gamma and in fact
this is the third pass we've made at
gamma we had a video on gamma and then
we made another one which we
originally called gamma reloaded so i
guess even more unoriginally we ought to
call this one gamma revolutions gamma is
this factor which comes up all over the
place in spatial relativity it's due
with you know when you have distances
being squashed when things are traveling
close to the speed of light the amount
they're squashed by is this factor of
gamma when time becomes dilated so time
becomes extended when something's
travelling first close to the speed of
light the amount is extended by is by
this factor gamma so it's a very sort of
fundamental piece of physics so
mathematically gamma
this factor is equal to one over square
root of one minus v squared over c
squared so if you've got an object or a
reference frame which is moving at speed
v then its gamma factor is this quantity
here so it's equal to
one when something's not moving if v is
equal to zero this quantity comes out as
one and as v goes up closest to gets
closer and closer to the speed of light
gamma gets bigger and bigger well one of
the things i said in probably the first
and the second video was actually if you
want to derive why gamma has that
particular form it's actually not that
difficult to do and so when you do that
then in the comments underneath the
video quite a lot of people say well go
on then do it do it go on um so that's
what we'll do we'll do it are you gonna
do math not very hard so the hardest
math here is pythagoras's theorem square
on the hypotenuse is equal to the sum of
the squares on the other two sides i
promised no harder than that we need to
back up a little bit and talk about
special relativity to do this the
fundamental principle in in special
relativity is that all reference frames
are the same and you can't tell if
you're as long as you're not
accelerating so if you're just moving at
uniform speed or stationary the laws of
physics are exactly the same so if
you're nothing called an inertial
reference frame you can't tell whether
that reference frame is moving or
whether it's still you'll end up you
know if you were inside a closed box in
there whatever experiments you could do
you'll always end up with the same laws
of physics you won't be able to tell i'm
moving and that guy is still or that guy
is moving and i'm still and everyone's
sort of familiar with that right that
basically you know if you're on an
aeroplane the laws of physics don't
change you know if you drop something
it's you know if you spill your coffee
it still ends up on your lap if you put
something in the microwave the microwave
oven still works on the airplane so the
laws of physics are the same
if you're moving at constant speed or if
you're stationary if you start
accelerating then obviously you can feel
the effects of the acceleration but as
long as you're moving at uniform speed
it makes no difference to any laws of
physics at all next part of the story is
electromagnetism which is says that you
know so going back to maxwell at the end
of the 19th century figured out these
laws of electromagnetism and from those
he derived the speed of light the speed
of light turns out has a very simple
form that is it's not in some sense a
fundamental constant if you know about
electrostatics how charges attract each
other if you know about magnetism how
magnets attract each other then actually
you can derive what the speed of light
is so the speed of light just comes from
simple physics it's not something that
you know it's just a made-up number it's
actually you can put in some simple
physics and derive what the speed of
light is
that means that because it comes from
simple physics
that means that the speed of light has
to be the same whatever reference frame
you're in right because it's just come
from some simple physics and the laws of
physics are the same whatever reference
frame you're in so whatever reference
frame you're in you should always see
the speed of light equal to the speed of
light now to get to the how we actually
get to gamma to do that we have to think
about clocks because clocks are one of
the things that get
affected by you know travelling close to
the speed of light that time slows down
and of course if time's slowing down
that means clocks can the speed at which
clocks are going is going to change but
everything's going to change you know
the speed at which radioactive decay
occurs the speed at which you age
everything is going to change just
because if they didn't all change
together then you'd know there was
something funny going on that suddenly
you know i'm only living 15 years
instead of 75 years and therefore
clearly something's changed with the
laws of physics so any clock you choose
to use
all other clocks have to mimic its
behavior so in special relativity when
you want to derive this equation you can
kind of set up a rather special kind of
clock a thing called a light clock and
so instead of having a pendulum that
ticks backwards and forwards you know
one tick per second you what you
actually have is you imagine you have a
light source
and a mirror
and what you do is you fire out a burst
of light that goes up hits the mirror
bounces back comes back and then you've
got a little detector next to the mirror
which says whenever i detect some light
i'm going to send out another burst of
light so really you've just got a little
burst of light going backwards and
forwards and it's just like a pendulum
clock in that sense that actually it's
sort of ticking backwards and forwards
between there and so you could use that
to measure time it's not very sensible
way to measure time but it's a perfectly
good way of measuring time and whatever
time you measure with this light clock
has to be the same as what you measure
with your pendulum clock or your
radioactive decay or whatever it is all
right so now we need to think about what
happens to such a clock so let me draw a
picture of it
so here we've got our light source we've
got a mirror up here and we've got a
little detector here so in you know in
simple terms all you're doing is you're
firing some light out there
it bounces back
and gets detected and then you've got a
little thing that says okay whenever i
detect some light i'll send another
pulse up and backwards and forwards
between these two and we'll make this
distance
a distance h
and if our clock's ticking supposing
it's period is tau so it does it takes a
time towel to go from there to there in
a time power from there to go from there
to there so which that's analogous to
like one second on a pendulum clock
because a pendulum actually only
completes a period every two seconds
right each it goes one way for a second
and then the other way for a second so
this is going to be a clock it's
probably if we make it you know the
trouble is if we wanted it to be a
second between ticks this thing would
have to be 300 000 kilometers long which
is not terribly practical so it's
probably gonna have a shorter tick but
we can write tau if we want that h
in terms of the period is c times tau so
basically it's tau to get from there to
their tau to come back again just like
from a pendulum clock one second to tick
one way one second to talk and that's
what would happen you know if i had one
of these clocks sitting next to me or
you know if actually i was sitting in a
rocket and i had one of these clocks
along along for the ride with me that's
what i'd see but now imagine i'm
watching somebody in a rocket so i'm not
moving the rocket is moving relative to
me and they've got one of these clocks
so they're watching it going tick-tock
and behaving in the way that we've just
derived here from the perspective of the
person in the rocket they're just seeing
the light going up and down but of
course the rocket from our perspective
is moving along which means that the
mirror is moving along and the light
source is moving along which means the
light instead of going up and down like
that is actually going like this from
our perspective it's going up then
coming down again so if i just draw that
what's happening is from the you know
the lights emitted at some point and
from our perspective we're seeing this
whole thing moving to the right so
actually what we see the light doing is
instead of going straight up we see the
light heading off in this direction
hitting the mirror because the mirror
has moved to the right by the time it
hits tip and then coming back down again
and of course by the time it gets back
down to the detector again the detectors
move to the right again
and so the light instead of going
straight up and down follows a path like
that
so it has further to go
from our perspective that light's gone
further
but also the speed of light is the same
in every reference frame
and so the light's got further to go and
it's traveling at the same speed so
therefore it takes longer to do it
so one of those ticks in our reference
frame takes longer than it did in the
reference frame in which the clock was
stationary just because the light's got
further to go and therefore it's going
to take longer to do it and we can
fairly straightforwardly mathematically
figure out how much longer it's going to
take to do it so let's go back to the
picture again for a second so this is
still this distant h
and that hasn't changed which we've
already said is equal to c times tau
that hasn't changed that's our ticks
that it would be
the light is now moving at the speed of
light
c we see it moving and it's going to
take some time
t to get where it's going so the
distance the lights traveled along here
is the speed of light times how long it
takes to get there c times t
okay and then remember this thing is
moving to the right it's moving to the
right at some speed v
which means by the time
the light has got to the top here this
thing will have moved the distance over
here how far it will move well if it's
moving at my speed v and it's got a time
t to do it then the distance it travels
is just v times t
and this is just a right angle triangle
we've got here and so we can apply
pythagoras theorem which says that the
hypotenuse squared is equal to the sum
of the squares on the other two skies so
ct squared is equal to
c tau squared plus vt squared so let's
just write that down we've got c squared
t squared because we squared the whole
thing so it's squeezed squared tau
squared
plus
v squared t squared now i need to do a
little bit of magic to rearrange this
formula t squared is equal to
tau squared over
1 minus v squared over c squared and
then i just take the square root of both
sides that tells me that the time i
measure in my reference frame is the
time you measure in the reference frame
in which the clock is stationary divided
by and i've got to take the square root
of the bit on the bottom
one minus v squared over c squared
which is just gamma that we defined
before times tau
so the factor of gamma is how much time
gets changed by how much time gets
multiplied by so this is saying that the
time we measure tac t is related to the
time
in the reference frame in which the the
clock is stationary so we'll think all
the proper time
by some factor is longer by a factor of
gamma so gamma is the amount by which
the time gets stretched and as promised
nothing harder than pythagoras theorem
somebody approaching the tunnel
if this happens it's not going to be
such good news because
from their perspective the train is
longer than the tunnel which means
either the front of the train gets
chopped off or the back of the train
gets chopped off or both